In the wake of the two nurses diagnosed with Ebola in Dallas...
...and the subsequent fear and fallout,...
...one measure that's been floated consistently...
...is that of a travel ban on the worst affected West African countries.
We should not be allowing these folks in, period.
Now is that time.
Let's put in place those travel restrictions that we're looking for.
So why all of this talk about a ban?
Fear could be one motivating factor.
After it was revealed that one of the nurses diagnosed with Ebola took a flight to Cleveland,...
...fears escalated that more people could have been exposed to the virus.
But another factor seems more and more to be politics,...
...with elections only a couple of weeks away.
Reporting for NPR, Juana Summers looks at how Ebola response has become a political debate,...
...getting wrapped up into the issue of national security and ISIS.
The coverage has overshadowed the original source of the outbreak.
Now, all of a sudden because there are cases in the West,...
...here in the United States, in Europe,...
...we're spending a lot of time covering those cases...
...and we're not talking about where the epicenter is, in Western Africa.
There, the CDC says close to 4500 people have died of the virus...
...and the number of total cases is nearing 9000.
For Newsy, I'm Sebastian Martinez.